If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in
God.
When Christ who is your life appears, then you will also appear with him. And
Well, good morning again, church. Uh,
what a gift it is to be together today as it is every Sunday. Uh,
you might notice some things that are a little bit different up here.
You might hear some things a little different. Uh,
this are now sadly HD screens. Great.
You can see everything. So, uh, anyway, uh, so that's that.
There's one screen missing yet here that will go between.
It'll have mostly lyrics on it. So just so you know,
we're not finished yet with even the lobby. So things are still working,
but we're thankful that, uh, it does sound incredible.
And we're excited to see how God's gonna continue to use that.
We're thankful for his provision through you and through the land and everything
that, uh, God did. If you're new to our church, I hope you feel welcomed.
We'd love to meet you. Hopefully we get a chance to, uh,
get to meet you and then you get to meet us.
So please come say hello to one of us up here or out there at the lobby.
Just say hi and get to know us. Wanna feel connected here. Uh,
that's what we hope for you feel as we get into it today.
How many of you ever forgotten something? Anybody ever forgotten anything?
Homework at school, maybe or, uh,
your credit card at a pizza place in Chickasha, uh,
not speaking from experience there or a Bitcoin password
to get $220 million? Anybody? No.
That was Stephan Thomas did that a few years ago,
so he must feel pretty badly. But forgetting things does make us feel terrible,
right?
Yet nothing we've ever forgotten in our daily lives
can compare to what we're gonna talk about today.
Potentially forgetting that has not only daily realities and
consequences, but eternal as well.
And so to see that,
take your copy of God's word and turn with me to Colossians chapter two.
It's in the New Testament, Colossians chapter two.
We're continuing through Colossians and we'll be in chapter two verses six
through 15 today as we take the fall to walk through Colossians
Colossians two, six through 15. Now, now verse six.
Marks a shift in the book itself in the letter that Paul's writing to
the church at Colossae. And,
and we know it's a shift because the massive first word in verse
six,
and this is something you should be looking for when you're reading the Bible by
yourself. What is this shift?
What's the word there that he used at the beginning of verse six? What is it?
Therefore, therefore, right. And so we need to ask what's the therefore,
therefore we need to understand why it's there.
It's a shift in his whole letter.
Because what that word means is anything that comes after that is based on what
he just said before that. So in other words,
what he's done with this whole introduction where he's talked about who God is,
he's talked about how we can, we can understand his salvation of us.
He's talked about the supremacy of Christ and all of this that we know and,
and come to understand about the gospel. He says, because of all of that,
do this. That's what we're about to see, is what he says then in response, like,
what is the therefore now leading us to in the body of the letter
Here it is starting with verse six, down through 15 today.
Therefore, as you received Christ, the Lord,
so walk in him rooted and built up in him and established in
the faith just as you were taught abounding in Thanksgiving.
See to it that no one takes you captive by philosophy.
An empty deceit according to human tradition,
according to the elemental spirits or principles of the world and not according
to Christ.
For in him the whole fullness of deity dwells bodily.
And you have been filled in him who is the head of all rule and authority
in him. Also,
you were circumcised with a circumcision made without hands by putting off the
body of the flesh, by the circumcision of Christ,
having been buried with him in baptism,
in which you were also raised with him through faith in the powerful working of
God who raised him from the dead.
And you who were dead in your trespasses and the uncircumcision of your flesh,
God made alive together with him having forgiven us all our trespasses
by canceling the record of debt that stood against us with its legal demands.
This he set aside, nailing it to the cross.
He disarmed the rulers and authorities and put them to open shame by
triumphing over them in him. God,
we need you to show us today what you want to show us.
We need your spirit to open our, our minds eyes,
our hearts eyes to see and feel and understand what you want us to see here.
How you want to change our lives, how you want us to see you differently.
Make us in our hearts good soil that this seed of the gospel plants
in and produces good fruit in our lives. God, this is your work.
It's not me. Get me outta the way.
Get get your word and and yourself at the center of everything today.
Teach us, show us, change us for your glory.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
So the thread that we're beginning to pull here will follow us through the next
few weeks of Colossians. In fact, pretty much the whole rest of Colossians,
'cause it goes back to the, the point of the entire letter.
Why was Paul writing this to them? Because remember,
this young church in Colossae was surrounded by a smorgasbord of other
religions. There were false religious practices and uh,
religious rituals and philosophies and practices and pagan things
all around, all happening right in their vicinity,
including a form of Judaism that was right at their doorstep.
And so people all around this church were saying that there were all kinds of
spiritual and material powers that even Christians were supposed to pacify.
Like you. You guys need to worry, okay, you can do your thing,
but you need to worry about these material and physical and spiritual powers out
there and you better do something to make them happy too.
That's what they were hearing.
And so the temptation for these new Christians was to get sucked into all of
these other beliefs and all these other practices and to lose the essence
of the gospel that had freed them.
That's why Paul made it a point to say to this young church that they needed to
remember the gospel.
Remember this gospel that they had received? Like just remember it.
'cause he's saying, you guys might have forgotten this.
He said this again already in chapter one, but, but here again very clearly,
he says, remember the gospel you received?
And look at verse eight. He says it this way,
see to it that no one takes you captive by philosophy.
An empty deceit according to human tradition,
according to the elemental principles of the world and not according to Christ.
Pretty clear, right?
Don't get sucked into all these worldly ideas,
including he mentions human traditions.
We'll talk a lot more about this next week. But,
but here he is referencing Jewish traditions.
How do we know he's talking about Jewish traditions? Well,
because he mentions circumcision in the next verse. And,
and circumcision for the Jews was a physical designation that they were God's
people.
Like it marked them off from the rest of society that this was something that
showed they were gods. And so Paul making a big deal about it here,
it's an indication that at least some people in the church were being tempted to
try to go back to Judaism. That, that maybe they had heard,
okay, Christ, that's fine, Jesus. Okay?
But you also have to do these Jewish things in order to make sure you're saved.
Well, that's why Paul here says what he says.
He reminds them of the gospel that they had received earlier,
that gospel that Romans one says is the power of God for the salvation of those
who believe nothing else. It's the gospel.
It's Jesus work in your place. He's saying, guys, you had received Christ,
Jesus the Lord, you were rooted, built up,
established in the faith that you were taught. So don't drift.
Well, what was this faith that they had been taught?
What was this gospel message that he's referencing here? Well,
it's one Corinthians 15, three and four. He says,
I delivered to you as of first importance. What I also received,
that Christ died for our sins in accordance with the scriptures. He was buried.
And then he was raised on the third day in accordance with the scriptures.
That's the gospel. In essence,
add one Timothy three 16, great indeed, we confess is the mystery of godliness.
That he Christ was manifested in the flesh, vindicated by the spirit,
seen by angels proclaimed among the nations,
believed on in the world and taken up in glory.
Like those were hymns of faith.
The gospel truth that they passed around at that time that just marked
in their minds, this is what the gospel actually is.
This is the truth that they could stand on.
This is the truth that they would be saved by.
This was the only thing they needed. Nothing else.
They didn't need to add anything to that gospel.
But just think about the culture and colossae,
I'm sure that those philosophies and the worldly principles
that they were hearing, I'm sure they were all really nicely packaged, right?
I mean, just think about the people who were spreading all of that information.
They were probably really good at what they were saying.
They were very easy to listen to.
These people would make it sound very appealing for these worldly philosophies
and principles Paul talks about to be believed.
And so it might have been fairly simple to slip into those things.
It might have been hard to resist.
These Christians again, might have heard from other people that, okay,
it's fine for you to worship Jesus,
but you also need to add all of these other things on top of it.
And it might've sounded good.
It might've appealed to their flesh that we kind of wanna work for our
salvation, don't we? And so they were like, well, maybe that's true.
That's why Paul went into this extended section on who
God is and what he's done. Like when you're identifying counterfeit money,
it's okay to be aware of what counterfeits can look like. But what do you do?
You study the real thing and know it so well that you can identify
any other false money, any other counterfeit money that might come your way.
'cause you know the real things so well, that's what Paul's talking about here.
His answer to the threats that the Colossians were facing
was to remind them of the God of their salvation.
He didn't try to answer everything. He does answer some,
but doesn't try to answer everything. He just says, no, no, remember, here's,
here's who God is. Remember who God is and what he's done for you.
And he says, Hey, if you really say you worship him,
then you should revere him.
Like you should revere this God, you say you worship right now.
Now that word revere, we don't use it a whole lot. Maybe Paul revere,
but that's not a different, that's a different thing, right? So,
so revering someone,
it means we respect, we love, we honor,
we give authority to, that's, that's how we revere someone,
even to the point where we, we maybe fear them a little bit
here. Here's how I heard it described years ago.
It's like when you're a little kid. So kids,
you might have had this actually happen recently to you,
like you're a little kid and you're standing there and this massive dog just
walks right up to you and it's taller than you are, but it it face-to-face,
it just stands right here, right?
So it's kind of cool and also a little terrifying that that dog
is this big right in front of you, right? That's in a sense,
kind of the idea we get here. That it's,
it's really cool to think about God and to to honor him. It's also should,
it also should be a little terrifying to us.
When we truly think about who God is,
we should revere God because of who he is.
And that's why Paul describes who he is.
Starting in verse nine, look at what he says about this God,
for in him the whole fullness of deity dwells
bodily. Who's he talking about? In whom is he referencing?
He's talking about Jesus. Now,
just let that marinate for a moment. Just,
just think about this for a second.
The whole fullness of deity,
all that God is
dwells in the body of Jesus
mind blowing hard to understand.
And I know saying that brings up some theological questions.
I I talked about this a couple weeks ago as well in chapter one,
as we start talking about, there's are deep,
profound things as we start to open this box of,
of the incarnation of Christ, and we talk about the Trinity, like there's,
there's hard things to grasp.
But notice what verse nine says.
It says not only that Jesus is fully God, even as he took on a fully human body,
that's the incarnation,
but there's also a more to God than just Jesus.
See,
I think we can get too Christ centric at times where we neglect the
fullness of God.
And I say that as we're in a series called Christ Above all I understand
I'm saying that in that context,
what we're saying with Christ above all is that in relation to
all the other philosophies and religious practices and worldview
around the people in Colossi Christ was and
still is above them all.
What we're not saying Is that God, the Son,
is somehow less than God the Father or God the Spirit,
or somehow more than God the Father or God the Spirit.
We're not saying anything about that. No, God is Trinity one God, three persons.
Here's how I read it this week. There is, but one,
living in true God everlasting without body parts or
passions of infinite power, wisdom and goodness.
The maker and preserver of all things both visible and invisible.
And in unity of this godhead, there'd be three persons of one, substance,
power, and eternity. The Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Now I know hard to understand, right? Yes,
it's really hard to understand,
but it's incredibly important for us to grasp this as best we can. God is God,
we're not. So we're not gonna fully understand it. But,
but this is one piece that distinguishes our beliefs from all other
religious practices and beliefs. I heard this,
I I'm gonna get the the number wrong so you can go check this. But,
but recently they did a survey of
church-going, people, like attending people,
not just ones who come on Christmas and Easter,
but but like you who are here almost weekly, right?
They did a survey and asked the questions theologically that, that we should,
should ask. Like, what is this? What is this? What is it? One of the questions
was the question, do Christians and Muslims worship the same God?
40 some percent said yes.
Hear that
40 some percent of people who go to church all the time
say, yeah, Allah, God almighty, they're the same.
Now I'm gonna answer that question for you,
that if you get a call from Barna or somebody,
you know how to answer the question. They're not the same.
They're not. This is the God we worship.
And one of the main things distinguishing that is the fact that it's one God,
three persons Trinity, right? That this is what is different. It's not the same.
We're not just looking perspectives. This and this. No, it's not the same.
This is God who is unique over all. And in him,
in Jesus, the body all thi all the fullness of God dwells
mind blowing but also encouraging, right?
But, but think about that all the fullness of God,
it dwells within Jesus bodily. Why would Paul say that?
Why would he write that here? Well,
he wrote that to remind the Colossians as verse 10 says, that,
that truth makes Christ the head of all rule and authority.
If he is God, all the fullness of God dwells within him bodily.
That means he is above all these other authorities, all these other powers,
all these other rulers,
everything else that they might be tempted to be pulled into,
they are underneath God Almighty.
And so Paul says, Hey guys, remember this is who he is.
So don't turn back to that stuff. You don't need that.
You've got God almighty, the fullness of God dwells within him.
And by the way, he says there,
the fullness of God also fills you with everything you will ever need in your
life. So don't, don't seek that stuff.
It's underneath the God you worship.
Now, that's just verse nine. There's more to this, right? Look further. Why?
Why should we revere God? Verse 11
in him, that's in Jesus. Also,
you were circumcised with the circumcision made without hands by putting off the
body of the flesh, by the circumcision of Christ.
And so he's talking again about the circumcision stuff. He's,
he's talking here about a spiritual circumcision that has nothing to do with
physical flesh.
It's cutting off the old sinful self that each one of us has.
And he's saying again to those people who would say, no,
you gotta be Jewish to be a Christian. No,
that's not what it's about anymore.
It's about the power of God to redeem sinners and mark them off himself.
How did he do that? He did that through his death where he,
he in a sense put off the body of flesh in his death.
He cut off the flesh so that the new covenant,
he could give us new hearts,
cut off the flesh sin of our hearts and say, here's something new.
That's what God does. Revere him,
talked about baptism. We got to celebrate that earlier in both services.
Praise God for that. But verse 12, he says it this way,
having been buried with him in baptism,
in which you are also raised with him through faith in the powerful working of
God who raised him from the dead.
So he does the same thing we do every time we baptize someone.
This is a tangible picture of the death and resurrection of Christ
that his death and resurrection is,
is creating a spiritual reality inside you. Not baptism itself,
but what it points to is what God does inside you.
And so think about it just like you saw when you go under the water,
it's a sign that you've already identified with the death of Christ on your
behalf. When you come up outta the water,
it's a sign that you've already identified with the resurrection of Christ on
your behalf.
And then all of that is done in faith, right? He says,
faith is what saves done in faith that one day fully,
he's going to resurrect your body.
Just like Jesus' was resurrected 2000 years ago. Like you're saying, God,
I believe that just like this symbolizes your death and resurrection someday I
get to be resurrected to you did it first. I get to do it someday as well.
And I believe in that. And so in other words,
Paul says to the Colossians, Hey,
if the God you say you worship can do all of that,
why turn back to anything else? Why do you need all the worldly philosophies?
Why do you need any of that other stuff? You've got all of this.
Don't get sucked back into that worldly stuff that's useless.
It's not even done. Verse 13, he talks to the Gentile Colossians,
especially because the Jews saw the Gentiles as, as in in a sense,
dead because they're outside of the covenant.
And then, so Paul says this in verse 13. He says,
you who were dead in your trespasses and the uncircumcision of your
flesh, that's the Jews saw them since they were uncircumcised. You're outside,
you're dead. And then you add this trespasses that that because we're sinners,
were spiritually dead. Man that puts the Gentiles in a bad place, doesn't it?
You're dead 'cause you're outside the covenant.
You're dead because you're a sinner in general. Like you are dead.
No hope yet. Verse 13 doesn't stop there.
God made you alive together with Jesus having forgiven us
all our trespasses, right? Just like God,
the Father reached into the life of the body of Jesus and made him alive.
He makes you alive spiritually by forgiving us our trespasses. So Paul saying,
Hey, Colossians, hey, hey Colossians, remember
it was Christ, it was Father,
it was God who made you alive spiritually.
None of the other stuff did those gods, those philosophies, they don't work.
God made you alive. So don't turn back to any of it.
Christ is enough. Don't turn back.
But you think, okay, God forgives sin. How does he do that?
Like does God just kind of, you know,
sweep it under the rug and kind of forget that it's even there?
Does he do any of that stuff? Like kinda ignore it? Is that how he forgives?
No. Look at verse 14,
forgiven us all our trespasses by canceling the record of debt that stood
against us with its legal demands. This he set aside,
nailing it to the cross.
This is most likely referring to the law of God,
which says that if we've broken any of it, we're guilty of breaking all of it.
So we have a record of debt. So, so imagine, here's the picture.
You're sitting in a courtroom and, and you're sitting there with,
with this record a debt.
And it doesn't matter how much you've tried to balance the scales,
it doesn't matter how much good you've tried to do to overcome that.
You sit there because of that record, guilty,
you've sinned against God. You are guilty, you have a debt,
and that debt is a debt that you can't pay back.
It's a chasm that you can't cross. It's a ransom that you could never pay.
But God can Right? Hear that you can't pay it,
you can't do it. God can, right? 'cause what does it say This, this record,
this guilty verdict. He set aside, nailing it to the cross.
Man, I got this picture this week. This is like it.
God took that guilty verdict. The rap sheet of all the stuff you've ever done,
all the guilty things that you are guilty for, right?
All the sins you've done against God. He took that rap sheet.
And just think about, think about the stacks of paper that would be,
just think about how deep that rap sheet is that you have.
Because if you're sending us God for your whole life and even the future ones
you're gonna do, he took that
and he put it up here on the wood of the cross,
put Jesus' hand in front of it. And as that nail was going through Jesus' wrist,
that hammer was hitting it not only through that,
but through that whole guilty verdict into that wood on your behalf,
right? That's what this says.
The stacks and stacks. Listen,
I know you're sitting here and some of you're like, I've done too much.
It doesn't matter how deep that stack is, it still goes through into the wood.
I know you're sitting there and you're thinking, I, I've gone too far.
And you're thinking about that thing that you hope nobody finds out about,
that you hope, nobody ever knows about. Listen,
God watched you do that.
And if you believe in him in your place, that's what happens.
That guilty, whatever gets there, Jesus' nail goes through his hand,
through that into the wood and it's carried, set aside, right? What a God
do you see this? What a God we serve. He's not just loving us,
he's not just forgiving us.
He's also paying the price for those sins that you and I commit against him.
He sets it aside. That word means erase.
It's gone. It's been nailed to the cross. It's finished
this. Do you see why Paul is saying to the Colossians,
Hey revere this God revere him because of all that he's done.
Because here's what that brings. Verse 15,
he disarmed as he did that he disarmed the rulers and authorities put
them to open shame by triumphing over them in him. That's a victory parade,
that word triumph.
He paraded them through shaming them.
Listen, this is what, this is what I, I heard I read about this week.
Everything they tried to do to Jesus, he did to them.
They stripped him naked. They shamed him.
They tried to take away his power by putting him on that cross.
And yet as they did that, Jesus stripped them.
He showed them shame. And he showed them to be powerless.
In the very act of them trying to overcome him, he overcame them.
That is the truth and the beauty of what we've seen, all of that,
everything from verses nine through 15,
all of that is why Paul said in verse eight,
see to it that no one takes you captive by anything else.
Don't be held captive by anything else. You've seen the power of God.
You've been freed by the power of God. You've been made alive in God.
So don't turn back to your dead captivity.
None of those things are philosophies or powers or anything can give you life.
The only way you find life is in Christ. Who is your life. Colossians three,
four says,
this week, a church member pointed out to me how the word captive here
reminds us of Israel. So many times in the Old Testament,
especially in the wilderness, especially on Mount Sinai,
and you'll get to that here in a second, but just think about this,
the Israelites, they were captives in Egypt. They were slaves.
They were held in captivity by, uh, Egypt.
Yet they saw the power of God to free them through the
10 plagues, through the splitting of the Red Sea to free them from captivity.
Yet as Moses went up on the mountain to receive the covenant
expectations from God what was happening at the base of the mountain,
they immediately, it says, began fashioning an idol,
a golden calf. And they pointed to it and said, this is our God now.
And all over the Old Testament, you see them say this phrase, in essence,
we, we wanna go back to Egypt, we want to go back.
It was better in Egypt. We want to go back to Egypt. This is our God,
we wanna go back.
It's like they had spiritual amnesia,
they had ungrateful hearts. They'd forgotten the character of God.
They'd forgotten what God had done for them. And so,
so how did God respond in that moment? Did he just write 'em off,
kicked them out, said, forget you, I'm gonna go find some new people.
Is that what he did? No,
he disciplined them and then he called them back,
invited them back, said, come back to me. Follow me.
Remember what I've done, the whole story, that Old Testament is this,
this cycle of how God looks at them,
calls them back, redeems them.
They follow him for a while and then they forget again. And they forget.
And they move back to these other idols and other falsehoods and,
and principles and powers. And they,
they get disciplined and God brings 'em back, calls 'em back,
and then they follow for a while and then they forget and they go back and they
seek more. It's just over and over and over and over again.
But I'm so glad that you and I are not like that, right?
We would never do that.
We would never turn our back on God and forget all that he's done for us
and turn to all this other silliness. We'd never do that, right?
We've gone so far, we've, we've progressed.
No, you know, I'm being facetious on that, right?
This is the story of every single one of us.
This is what you and I do. Every one of us. And, and listen,
maybe you're still dead in your sin and you're not even aware of coming
to God.
This is my prayer today is that you would see God rightly in Christ today,
all that he's done for you. You would turn to him in faith and say, I'm all in.
I need you. I can't do it myself. I'm exhausted.
I'm tired of chasing all this other stuff to try to find my fulfillment.
It's not happening.
My prayer is that you see him and you turn to this redeeming, restoring,
renewing, victorious God that he is.
But for all of us who are already believers, already
every one of us is prone to this, to the same things.
The Colossians were tempted by what Israel did in the wilderness. John Calvin,
he said that our hearts are idol factories.
We just keep creating new idols, coming up with new things to chase and pursue.
And this is gonna fulfill me. This is gonna fulfill me.
And we chase after all of it,
we drift from this reverence of God to all these worldly philosophies and
principles.
And so we chase, after every Instagram influencer that sounds good,
appeals to us in some way, that that's gonna be the fulfillment or,
or every new gadget that we see come up on Amazon.
Or we gotta buy that and buy that, that's gonna fulfill this. Or,
or we gotta keep up with the new house every couple years because that's the
image I need to have for other people.
Or we, we pick a talking head on TV and that becomes the truth.
And everything about it they say is absolutely right.
Or or the, the spiritual gurus on TikTok that just sound like, man, this,
this sounds good. That sure seems to make logical sense.
I think that's what I need to believe.
Or every theological shift made to
affirm our sinful behavior.
Listen, young people especially,
but all of us are prone to this. Hear me?
You are tempted right now to create your own truth all over the place.
Truth is not something you create. Hear me.
Truth is something you discover because there's only one.
You can't have your truth and their truth and they compete somehow. It,
it is not true. Right? It it, it's,
it's discovering the truth. That's what we're talking about here.
We do all of those things.
We chase after all these worldly principles and philosophies.
'cause we think somehow that's gonna satisfy us.
But those are all deceitful,
worldly philosophies and principles they can never satisfy.
They can never fulfill you. No matter what it feels like,
what you think about it, it will never satisfy.
The only thing that can fill you is the one who made you.
The only one who can fill you is the one who created you. The one listen.
The one in whom the whole fullness of deity dwells bodily, the head of all else,
the resurrector, the giver of new life, the victor over all things.
Like when you think about that, is there ever any really comparison here?
Is there really any comparison? Paul's saying to them, Hey guys,
remember this is who God is. And don't forget, you already know this God,
you already know him. So why do you need to turn back to all this other stuff?
You're not sitting back here trying to make objective decisions. Well,
this one makes right. This one makes right. This seems right. Like no,
you already know. If you're in Christ, you know him already. So don't turn away.
Why would you walk back into slavery in captivity
when you have freedom?
He's already put all those things to shame. He's already proved them powerless,
proved them worthless.
So
Why go back?
As I've already said, it's the same for us today though, right?
And so the question we need to ask, why do we keep doing it?
Why do we keep going back? Why do we keep drifting?
Why do we keep thinking about this is better than this that we have in Christ?
Why?
Because not only do we have spiritual amnesia, we have gospel amnesia.
We forget this gospel.
And we instead begin to think on the worldly philosophies and sin and
temptations. And that's where we get our minds focused instead of remembering.
And so church, listen, this is why we gather here.
This is why this is essential for us.
That's why your time in the word by yourself daily,
regularly is essential. That's why time with brothers and sisters is essential.
Because you and I need to be reminded of these things.
We quickly forget, we quickly run away. We forget.
And so we needed to be reminded every day. Well,
lemme remind you today of this gospel truth,
That Jesus lived the perfect life you should have lived.
He died the death you deserved for that sin.
And he defeated the enemy of sin and death by coming outta the grave alive on
the third day. And now he sits ascended,
reigning over all things and he's coming back one day, right?
That is the gospel that he has done that to forgive you and to free you
from the captivity of your sin. That's what he's done for you church.
Remember that? And so hear that when you remember that.
What you need to remember is that whatever he's tempting you with right now,
he's already overcome it. He's already defeated it, right?
If that's the truth of the gospel,
you don't need to be sucked into what the enemy's tempting you know,
he's already won
whatever is reminding you of the deadness of your past.
You
Need to remember that Christ has made you alive. You're already alive.
You're not dead anymore. You're alive.
Whatever's claiming a debt against you. No, you're still guilty.
You've gone too far,
you've done too much whatever's claiming a debt against you. See this.
He's already nailed it to the cross. Remember,
this is the truth of the gospel. So hear me.
Don't be held captive by any of that stuff.
You are free from it.
If you have believed on the Lord Jesus Christ in your place, you are free.
Stop going back to captivity
and listen, be full of gratitude for that too, right?
Oh man,
If this is who God is and this is what he has done,
be full of gratitude.
We don't deserve any of it. We couldn't earn any of it,
and we regularly turn away from it.
And yet God in His grace has saved us. He's redeemed us.
He's made us new like, oh man,
grateful heart. That's why Paul says here abounding in thanks, giving.
That's what should completely change our lives.
A life filled with gratitude.
Listen,
the less that we reflect on what God has done for us,
the quicker we run to all these other things and forget the gospel.
But the more we reflect on the good news of Christ,
the more we think about it, the slower our eyes drift to other things,
The slower we,
we see our our lives look opposed to Christ.
The more we reflect on his grace, the more our faith is rooted,
built up in Him and established in him. The more we reflect,
the more we remember, the more we'll gratefully,
gratefully walk in him just as we've received him.
The more we reflect on the gospel, more,
we're reminded of who he is and what he's done,
the more we're going to share that faith with people at school,
with people at work, people in our home, people here at church,
and for some of you to the ends of the earth as well.
That's why here
we focus way more on what he has done for you
over what you need to do for him or do differently in your life.
Because our only sure foundation is what he's already done rather than how well
we're gonna do at this thing, right?
And because we so quickly forget,
we need to be reminded over and over and over of this
gospel that he is our solid foundation, that he is the one who's changed us,
that he is doing a work in us. There's no need. Hear me.
There's no need to fall back into the captivity of
worldly principles and philosophies. He's enough.
So let's live for him in that.